Alexia et Jonathan donc se sont
rencontrés en 2005 se mettent en couple
alors qu'il a 21 ans et elle 16 ans et
au début tout se passe bien dans leur
couple
tout se passe bien tout va bien vous
entendez bien avec Alexia au début on
est bien vous la présente la première
fois c'est vous dites c'est c'était très
gentil très lunaire très très bien
tout se passe bien il se marie en 2015
et c'est là que les choses vont
doucement sont venus de l'extérieur vous
voyez que leur couple Madeleine ou pas
du tout tu peux un petit peu mais pas
voilà c'est pas plus inquiétant que ça
il continue chez vous voilà ils étaient
comment vous voilà ils se disputaient ou
bien
ils étaient comment ils étaient amoureux
vous les sentiments
très amoureux oui oui c'est peut-être
très amoureux ah non vous le ressentiez
comme ça mettre c'est ce que vous aviez
dit très amoureux
de d'Alexia et pour reprendre Martine
c'est pas lunaire c'est solaire
mais on a qu'à voir les photos on est
encore on est encore à une période où
ils sont très heureux et très proches
l'un de l'autre ça va se dégrader la
dernière année en réalité
le drame intervient donc ce 28 octobre
2017 Jonathan alerte la police pour
signaler la disparition d'Alexia
Planard adénoïde ou qui avait coécrit le
livre
cette affaire vous l'avez suivi comme
tous les Français
quand on vous a demandé de coécrire ce
livre vous aviez bien sûr ce moment où
on a cette image qu'on a tous quand
Jonathan Daval arrive à la tribune et
t'ampleur voilà bien sûr alors j'ai
suivi aussi comme journaliste et j'avais
déjà eu l'occasion de rencontrer Martine
avant au procès et évidemment que j'ai
comme tous les Français cette image de
Jonathan qui pleure à la marche blanche
mais quand on a suivi le procès et quand
on connaît un petit peu le dossier on
voit que c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué un petit peu plus nuancé que
que l'image qu'on en a en fait donc
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
bien entendu ce soir c'est vous qui avez
proposé à Martine d'écrire
donc au procès mais elle ne s'en
souvient pas parce qu'elle elle était
dans son procès elle était perturbée
évidemment elle avait pas que ça à faire
de se souvenir de moi mais moi en fait
elle m'avait déjà ému
par son côté maman maman envers et
contre tout ça m'avait touché moi aussi
en tant que maman et puis je travaillais
en tant que journaliste avec Matt schwar
dorfer je vous rejoins sur ce que vous
avez dit voilà c'est je le trouve très
bonne avocat et en fait comme lui
connaissait bien Martine puisque il
s'est lié d'affection avec elle aussi
parce qu'on peut pas ne passer
d'affection avec Martine il m'a dit ça
collerait bien entre vous et comme enfin
bref Martine n'avait aussi besoin de
dire sa vérité au bout d'un moment on
est deux ans après le procès du coup est
né ce projet ce projet de livre
maman de Jonathan les non-dits de
l'affaire Daval alors
Martine vous vous souvenez de ce fameux
jour ce 28 octobre 2017 bien entendu ah
oui
vous souvenez de quoi qu'est-ce qui vous
vient en tête en premier
les gendarmes étaient tous dans la
maison et puis que j'avais pas le droit
de passer j'avais pas le droit de voir
vous l'avez appris comment
par mon mari qui passe il allait au
boulot et puis il a passé dans la rue il
m'a appelé il savait pas ce qui se
passait parce qu'il a pas pu passer j'ai
appelé
notre fils Stéphanie elle était voir et
puis c'est là qu'elle nous a dit oui il
y a plein de gendarmes c'est tout est
barré donc là vous apprenez on vous dit
quoi on m'a rien dit du tout au début je
suis allé directement sur place et là et
là j'ai bien vu que c'était plein de
monde dans la maison pleinement plein de
gendarmes
pas une seule fois vous n'imaginez que
Jonathan puisse être impliqué dans la
disparition de sa femme pas du tout une
seule fois j'ai non pour moi c'était pas
lui
j'avais parlé avec lui pour vous c'était
impensable
c'est pas Jonathan pourquoi il vous dit
quoi quand vous
sa femme disparue il vous dit quoi les
jours qui suivent les heures qui suivent
vous dites quoi
il est député il est pas bien oui c'est
sûr qu'il était pas bien puis après vous
savez il y a tellement une chose que
je suis plus
elle dit
on sait pas un instant mettre que ce
soit Jonathan à ce moment-là forcément
dit qu'elle n'imagine pas un moment
parce qu'elle ne reconnaissent pas son
fils elle le dit très bien dans son
livre c'est à dire que
moi qui ai rencontré Jonathan Daval avec
Maître Spatafora à un moment on s'est
dit ça peut être lui
une fois qu'on a parlé avec lui c'était
un a priori un préjugé on n'est pas
témoin on ne séparément ce qui s'est
passé mais on s'en est même voulu de
l'avoir soupçonné d'avoir pu tuer sa
femme tellement ça ne lui ressemble pas
et c'est ça qui est passionnant et très
intéressant dans le livre de Martine
c'est qu'elle aborde aussi ce double
visage de Jonathan c'est à dire que il y
a l'enfant qu'elle connaît qu'elle a mis
au monde les qualités qu'à cet enfant
les fragilités aussi de Jonathan et il
en a dans sa construction de jeunes
enfants d'adolescents la gentillesse qui
est la sienne habituellement son
comportement enfin toutes ses qualités
qu'on lui reconnaît et par contre c'est
ultra ce qu'il y a eu ce jour là ce
passage à l'acte ou même Jonathan Daval
encore du mal lui-même à admettre qu'il
soit lui-même l'homme qui a fait ça et
pourtant c'est lui et pourtant c'est lui
alors vous vous allez bien sûr
l'entourer les jours qui ont suivi la
disparition bien sûr d'Alexia
tout à fait on reste avec lui dans la
maison et au fur et à mesure que
l'enquête avance les soupçons vont
pourtant s'orienter vers votre fils
est-ce que vous le sentez est-ce que
vous le sentez un moment que ça ça
tourne et que on sent que Jonathan a
quelque chose à voir avec cette
disparition non je m'en suis pas aperçue
mais Jonathan me disait souvent tu sais
maman c'est toujours le mari le
meurtrier et ils vont un jour ils vont
venir me chercher puis moi je disais non
c'est pas possible c'est pas toi
et là ben il coupait net parce que je
voulais pas admettre qu'il est pouvait
être dedans en vous disant ça peut-être
qu'il essayait de vous
dire quelque chose et j'ai pas voulu le
comprendre enfin je l'ai pas compris du
tout
de suite vous éludiez le la question
c'est ça c'est
à ce moment-là vous le dit plusieurs
fois vous dites quand on sent que c'est
Jonathan qu'il est interpellé vous dites
qu'il y a forcément une erreur ou là
vous commencez à y croire non toujours
pas non toujours pas à ce moment-là
vous dites c'est Jonathan de me l'avait
dit de toute façon ils vont venir le
chercher parce que je suis le maintenant
vous aviez une théorie vous personnelle
sur sur la disparition
Xavier
elle serait pas montée avec quelqu'un
dans une voiture
non à quel moment est-ce que c'est vrai
que c'est de plus en plus tard vous
réalisez enfin que ces gens-là
on a compris beaucoup de choses parce
que bon il y a des choses que je savais
pas bien sûr et là c'est là que j'ai dit
oui c'est seulement là que j'ai pu
comprendre que c'était bien Jonathan
quand elle parle de ces choses qu'elle
apprend procès qui ont fait que elle a
compris que c'était Jonathan plana et
maître schwar dofer elle parle de quoi
Martine et en fait Martine elle dit une
chose qu'elle explique très bien dans
son livre et que la dernière des novic
c'est que en tant que maman elle aurait
tellement aimé que ce soit pas lui et
que inconsciemment elle a projeté ça sur
Jonathan qui l'a aussi senti et je pense
que ce sont notamment les mensonges
qu'elle explique de Jonathan quand il
accuse Grégory gay il aurait aimé lui
aussi pouvoir dire à sa mère c'est pas
moi pour retrouver dans les yeux de sa
mère ce qu'il voyait avant que tout ça
se soit passé il aurait tellement aimé
ne pas avoir fait ça et je pense
qu'effectivement il a notamment aussi
menti à sa mère et inc je pense que
Martine c'est la soulagé de se dire
c'est pas mon fils accepter que ce soit
son fils Martine elle a rien fait c'est
jamais eu de problème de sa vie elle a
élevé six enfants du jour au lendemain
elle se voit partout à la télé son fils
est accusé de meurtre c'était froyable
leur vie s'était fondée à tous à la
famille fouillot la famille Henri Daval
c'est catastrophique et je crois que
Martine a secrètement tellement espéré
que ce soit pas lui que quand elle se
rend compte que c'est lui c'est vraiment
l'effondrement et au procès simplement
c'est que Jonathan va tout dire il va
dire ce qu'il a fait il va dire les
coûts il va dire l'étranglement il va
dire comment il a tiré le corps on va
rentrer dans la chose criminelle
martinella elle entend elle écoute c'est
terminé c'est bien son fils qui est un
meurtrier et c'est ce qu'elle explique
dans son livre c'est ce que je dis dans
mon dans ma postface plane m'a permis
d'écrire mais ça a été son choix ensuite
d'assumer en tant que maman d'être la
mère d'un enfant d'un homme qui est
devenu un meurtrier c'est une place très
difficile
quand on a un enfant qui bascule dans la
délinquance une place très difficile
elle a fait le choix d'assumer elle a
fait le choix d'affronter elle a fait le
choix d'aider toute sa famille de
continuer à regarder Jonathan sans le
juger c'est pas un juge c'est sa mère et
elle essaye d'expliquer quelle est la
place d'une mère confrontée à un tel
drame il y en a beaucoup des maires
comme Martine il y a pas beaucoup de
Martine Henri je le dis aussi dans ce
que je vois mais c'est une place très
difficile c'est son choix et c'est la
plage je trouve d'une femme d'une femme
forte et d'une femme bien voilà malgré
tout vous dites Jonathan reste votre
fils oui Jonathan mon fils quels sont
vos rapports avec lui aujourd'hui
ça va très bien on a retrouvé un peu
pour se parler puis notre complicité
vous le voyez régulièrement
tous les 15 jours
pour vous
impression vous dites que Jonathan c'est
c'est quelqu'un de bien ça reste votre
fils mon fils était quelqu'un de bien
avant il a fait avant la connerie voilà
et il redevient quelqu'un de bien bon il
est enfermé il est en prison mais il
reste toujours quelqu'un de bien rien ne
dit que il pourrait refaire ça un jour
comprenez que ça puisse choquer
d'entendre ça
donc moi je trouve pas choquant moi
un fils les enfants restent des enfants
on peut pas parce qu'il est passé
meurtrier qu'il faut plus aimer son
enfant on peut pas le laisser tomber non
plus il faut être présent
moi j'ai besoin de lui comme lui il a
besoin de moi
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit les parents
d'Alexia après ils ont pas parlé
vous étiez proche de on était proche on
se voyait oui sans plus les relations
étaient cordiales
[Musique]
depuis près de 5 ans maintenant Jonathan
Daval est derrière les barreaux comme on
vous le trouvez comment il est mieux
il a bien récupéré
dans sa tête il paraît mieux si vous
permettez parce que Martine l'écrit très
bien et que c'est difficile de
s'exprimer sur un plateau et comme dit
Martine dans ses yeux il y a quelque
chose qui a changé c'est ce que c'est ce
que Martine et on sent que de toute
façon on va pouvoir revu chaque fois que
j'ai revu de Jonathan Daval moi je suis
pas son je suis pas son père je suis pas
son ami je suis son avocat mais je j'ai
l'habitude
ses yeux et dans ses yeux on voit que
c'est quelqu'un qui porte le poids de ce
qu'il a fait on voit que c'est quelqu'un
qui vit constamment avec
l'idée le remord et le regret de ce
qu'il a fait c'est quelque chose qui se
ressent profondément Martine enfin plana
aussi l'explique très bien dans le lit
ça a changé irrémédiablement voilà il
n'a plus jamais été heureux alors bien
sûr que tout le monde va dire c'est
normal
oui c'est pas ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est quelle est la place
d'une maman par rapport à son fils quand
son fils a fait le pire justement c'est
simplement ce que c'est d'expliquer
Martine comme vous dites Cyril ça peut
choquer bien sûr ça peut choquer mais
est-ce que ce serait pas plus choquant
d'une maman qui abandonnerait son fils
en disant et bien puisque tu es devenu
un meurtrier tu n'es plus de notre
famille on ne te parlera plus on ne
viendra plus te voir on va nous aussi te
juger une deuxième fois alors que la
société l'a déjà fait la société t'a
condamné t'a mis en prison ben nous
notre place c'est de dire que malgré
tout on t'aime malgré le pire et on
reste près de toi sans excuser une seule
seconde c'est aussi le livre de Martine
sans excuser une seule seconde je n'ai
jamais entendu Martine avoir la moindre
complaisance envers dans le geste les
gestes criminels qu'avaient commis de
Jonathan il faut bien comprendre ça ça
peut paraître compliqué après mais en
réalité sa place est terriblement
compliquée Martine s'en navire parlé que
Jonathan
non jamais non une fois qu'il est qu'il
a été incarcé
comment vous le vivez aujourd'hui parce
que vous savez qu'il va y rester très
très très longtemps
mais on vit au jour le jour notre vie a
complètement changé
et on vit au jour le jour où on se lance
plus dans des projets
on fait plus rien alors il y a une
information qui a été donnée par le
journaliste dominicrisé il a quelques
jours
regardez tout le monde en a parlé vous
avez donné votre avis là-dessus ce qui
est sur ce qu'il est bien
dans sa maison centrale est en couple
avec un homme il a rencontré là-bas un
garçon un peu plus âgé que lui avec
lequel il vit une histoire histoire de
prisonnier c'est vrai que c'est ta
formation évidemment c'est sa vie privée
mais elle apporte un éclairage à cette
affaire différents tout le monde a
cherché à comprendre il avait des
troupes de l'érection prenez des
médicaments elle lui avait envoyé un
jour un SMS en lui disant enfin elle
parlait à une de ses amis elle avait
envoyé un sms Alexandre de ses amis en
lui disant je crois que même si je me
mène nu devant lui il ne se passe rien
il me regarde même pas
alors vous avez des mentir cette
information
qu'est-ce que vous avez quand vous avez
vu ça vous êtes dit quoi j'ai dit non
mais ça va pas la tête
j'en ai parlé Jonathan oui c'est moi qui
l'ai prévenu est-ce qu'on allait le voir
ce jour-là
que Monsieur Rizet disait que il était
en couple avec un garçon puis j'ai dit à
Jonathan si c'est vrai tu me le dis ça
changera rien tu aimeras toujours
pour nous ça changera rien il m'assuré
que non c'était pas vrai et puis comme
j'ai dit qu'il soit en couple avec un
garçon ou une fille ça ne regarde pas la
France c'est sa vie privée à lui
tout ce qu'il a dit
des excuses
aujourd'hui donc dans votre livre vous
sortez aujourd'hui je vous avais des
mots assez durs à un contre Alexia mine
de rien
dit
si je peux me permettre martine a
toujours dit Alexia ne mérite pas ça
personne ne mérite ça elle est toujours
très peinée pour Alexia qui est que
voilà forcément pour la famille etc et
en fait ce que Martine tient à dire
Martine c'est quelqu'un de très honnête
bon aussi très cash parfois mais qui en
fait elle tient à dire Alexia c'était
pas un ange c'était un être humain comme
tout le monde donc elle avait des
qualités des défauts et donc elle ce
qu'elle explique c'est que elle dit
voilà comment moi je connais Alexia
Alexia qui disait à Jonathan de pas
aller voir sa maman par exemple les deux
familles qui s'entendaient pas forcément
etc mais elle veut par honnêteté dire
comment ça se passait parce que ce
qu'elle a vu d'Alexia et ce qu'elle a vu
de la relation qu'elle avait avec avec
son fils alors il y a une phrase qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit et que certains
vous reprochent je vous dis sinon on se
dit tout ce soir un maître et dans une
interview vous avez déclaré vous n'étiez
pas inquiète pour votre fils et qui sont
dans des très bien avec Guy Georges Guy
Georges et l'un des tueurs en série les
plus connus de France purgent peine à
perpétuité depuis 2001 après avoir
reconnu après avoir été reconnu coupable
de cette meurtre
voilà c'est très content prison ils sont
voilà et ces Jonathan qui vous a dit ça
je le vois moi-même parce que Monsieur
Guy Georges bon il a fait ce qu'il a
fait il était jugé donc moi déjà ça nous
concerne pas et mais il vient nous dire
bonjour donc on lui répond bonjour aussi
ils sont ils se parlent avec Jonathan il
se côtoient là-bas en prison peuvent
faire grand-chose d'autre donc pour moi
Guy Georges je m'occupe pas de ce qu'il
a fait c'est pour moi c'est un être
humain oui je sais je vous dis la phrase
elle a fait polémique quand vous avez
dit ils sont entends très bien avec
Dijon voilà donc c'est c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui même aujourd'hui c'est
encore c'est encore en top tweet
[Musique]
moi je les côtoie aussi les plus grands
criminels dont on parle de leur serre la
main je leur parle parce que c'est mon
métier d'avocat quand vous allez en
prison et quand vous êtes incarcéré pour
des faits criminels vous rencontrez
d'autres criminels avec qui forcément
vous cohabiter vous coexister vous avez
des activités communes vous vous parlez
la prison Guy Georges n'est pas dans une
cellule isolée où tout le monde
jetterait des des détritus pour le punir
jusqu'à la fin de séjour Guy Georges il
a une vie de détenus ordinaire en maison
d'arrêt où il est en centre de détention
easytheim c'est un détenu ordinaires il
salue et il parle avec les surveillants
il leur serre la main certainement qui
peut jouer parfois aux échecs avec un
surveillant que ça puisse choquer les
gens qui ne mettent pas les pieds en
maison d'arrêt qui ne connaissent pas la
chose criminelle c'est une chose mais
c'est ce que dit Martine c'est le
quotidien la rencontre tous les sens des
tensions et elle le voit effectivement
quand vous allez ensemble de détention
moi j'ai rencontré des criminels très
connus qui quand il me voit viennent me
voir bonjour mes chers de refaire vous
allez bien vous avez vu j'ai lu votre
livre et on parle mais on va paru juger
une deuxième fois on va pas condamner
systématiquement une personne parce
qu'elle a déjà été condamnée du Georges
il est à sa place et personne ne dit que
il a rien fait personne ne dit qu'il a
été mal jugé on dit simplement
qu'effectivement quand vous croisez Guy
Georges dans son centre de détention qui
vous dit bonjour vous lui répondez
bonjour alors voilà Martine aujourd'hui
aussi je vous dis je vous dis tout voilà
ce qui se dit aussi il y a pas mal de
gens aussi qui se disent qui comprennent
pas et ça je vais pas la Plana et à
Martine qui disent pourquoi écrire un
livre là-dessus il y a des gens qui vous
critiquent qui disent pourquoi aller
faire de l'argent sur une affaire
pareille et sur un drame pareil plana
est-ce que vous répondez
alors si vous voulez déjà je le fais pas
pour l'argent d'accord
c'est plus pour moi une thérapie
parce que ça m'a fait du bien de pouvoir
sortir un peu ce que j'ai en moi
donc si ça choque les jambes ma foi je
voulais que je vous dise toute façon que
ça soit d'un côté d'une famille ou d'une
autre on sera toujours choqué mais pour
ce qui est de l'argent j'ai dû insiste
déjà on sait que enfin peut-être les
gens savent pas le grand public mais on
devient pas milliardaire en faisant des
livres sinon ça se saurait mais aussi
Martine ne voulait rien du tout j'ai dû
insister comme une malade pour qu'elle
touche un petit pourcentage sur les
droits d'auteur
et voilà donc je sais qu'elle voulait
rien prendre au départ vraiment et que
vous avez
pas tout prendre pour le coup c'était
bizarre et juste je voulais rajouter
aussi que on a beaucoup entendu la
vérité des de la famille d'Alexia a
juste titre ils avaient besoin de ses
pencher mais Martine on l'avait pas
entendu ou très peu et en fait elle
aussi elle a son vécu sur l'affaire elle
aussi elle a sa vision de la faire en
une minute c'est quoi vous votre votre
vision de la faire
que mon fils
meurtrier puis que il va passer des
années des années sur les circonstances
sur sur ce qui a causé ce drame c'est
quoi votre avis là-dessus c'est quoi
votre sentiment c'est quoi quand vous
raconteriez l'histoire
c'est compliqué ça c'est peut-être
compliqué pour elle de résumer en une
minute mais
ouais parce que je pense que je pense
que le point de vue de Martine c'est un
point de vue qui va humaniser Jonathan
Daval forcément puisque c'est sa maman
donc elle elle lui trouve aussi des
qualités et elle va un peu nuancer le
côté un petit peu binaire un petit peu
blanc noir il y a la victime qui est
forcément parfaite et le coupable qui
est forcément un monstre elle elle vient
dire c'est d'ailleurs le titre de votre
teasing Jonathan c'est pas un monstre
c'est quelqu'un qui a commis quelque
chose d'horrible mais c'est aussi mon
fils que j'ai élevé elle raconte sa
naissance son enfance etc elle nuance en
fait ce tableau là je pense
mes enfants regardent oui lui je sais
pas vous tenez le coup
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que il faut
aller de l'avant
mais moi j'ai pas j'ai pas honte il a
fait ça j'aime pas avoir honte
non pas du tout non pas du tout ni les
voisins ni personne non merci d'avoir
été là merci
je voulais vous dire qu'on est triste
aussi malgré tout pour Alexia
pour la famille d'Alexia surtout aussi
qui qui malheureusement comme vous avez
dit vous passez des moments avec
Jonathan encore malheureusement les
parents d'Alexia c'est le moment avec
elle et vous vous en passez encore et ça
c'est le c'est vraiment c'est ça qu'ils
doivent penser ce soir